in this video we're going to go through
eight problems talking about
transformations of some different parent
functions
see if you can do these problems on your
own and we'll go through them together
you might want to take a screenshot or
write these problems down so that you
can attempt them on your own and keep in
mind that there's more than one correct
way to do some of these transformations
however there are ways that you may
think that you can do the
transformations which will give you the
incorrect final graph so try to be real
careful with the order of
transformations also try to identify
what exactly is the parent function
and then go ahead and list the order of
transformations
first thing we'd like to do here before
we dive into the problems is just kind
of review a little bit about the
different rules or ways of looking at
what's happening to a parent function
so the first thing
that we want to take a look at here
is
this one here f of x plus k now keep in
mind f of x is like our parent function
and then when you add
k to that parent function what it does
if k is positive is going to translate
or slide or shift that graph up by k
whereas if k is negative it's going to
then
translate or shift or move that graph
down by whatever k is so if it was minus
three it would shift down three if it
was plus three it would shift up three
now if we go down to the second
rule here you can see a
is being multiplied
by the function so you're taking that
function you're multiplying it by some
value a if a is greater than 1 like 1.5
2 3 4 then what it does is it stretches
by whatever that
a value is by that factor so if it's 2
it would basically stretch it in the y
direction or the vertical direction by a
factor of 2. now if a was between 0 and
1 like a half for example then we say
it's a vertical shrink by a factor of
whatever a is
and then lastly if a is a negative value
then what it does is it reflects the
graph over the x-axis so it's just going
to take that whole graph and do the
mirror image or reflect it over the
x-axis
now let's jump down to this last one
before we get to this third one here so
the last one f of x minus h
notice that this x minus h is in
parenthesis it's grouped with the x so
when it's grouped with the x we know
that it's going to move the graph in the
x direction the horizontal direction and
we say that it's a horizontal shift
by by whatever h is now
keep in mind if it's in parentheses and
it's like x minus 3 it will actually
have the opposite effect with the minus
three people think left three but no
it's actually going to shift it to the
right three if it's x plus three it's
going to shift it to the
left three so it actually
appears to be a little bit
opposite from the sign but if you see
here x minus h if it's x minus 3 it's
actually shifting to the right positive
3. see
and then the last one that sometimes
students struggle with is
where it's f of a times x okay and you
can see again that a value is grouped
with the x okay it's in parentheses it's
it's grouped with the x and what happens
is if a is greater than one
what it does is actually a horizontal
shrink by
one divided by a so for example if this
was f of 2x it would actually multiply
all the x values by one half and that's
what shrinks it horizontally in the x
direction
now
if the a value is between 0 and 1
then it's going to be a horizontal
stretch
by a factor of 1 over a again the
reciprocal so if a was like one half
like if this is one half x
you know grouped in parentheses like
that then it's actually going to be 1
divided by a half which is actually 2 so
it multiplies the x values by 2 and
stretches it horizontally by a factor of
2.
and then lastly if a is a negative okay
and again group with the x then it's
going to reflect it over the y-axis is
basically making all the x values the
opposite sign which reflects it over the
y axis
okay so let's dive into the problems now
so this first one number one y equals
two times the absolute value of x plus
one so the parent function here is
y equals the absolute value of x right
and we know this isn't really
going to be going into the graphing so
much in this video i'll put a link to
another video if you want talking about
how to actually graph these but this is
basically a v shape graph that absolute
value graph
and when you're talking about the order
of transformations here what's going to
happen is we're going to be
multiplying the
y values by two it's a vertical stretch
by a factor of two
followed by
a translation up one
so in this case there was really only
one way to do this uh
order of transformations vertical
stretch by a factor of two which if
you're interested in the graph it's
going to basically make this graph a
little bit steeper because you're you're
stretching it or pulling it in the y
direction you're multiplying all those y
values by two okay
and then the plus one would then on the
next step would take that graph and
would shift it up
one unit and it would look something
like that
so
we'll talk about the graphing in another
video but for now let's focus on the
parent function and then the order of
transformations which is oftentimes
confusing for students okay for number
two now what did you get for the parent
function did you get
y equals
x squared so that's your core function
that's your basic function that you're
working with again keep in mind you know
x squared is a quadratic function and
it's a parabola shape when you graph it
but as far as the order of
transformations here notice we have a
few things going on here we've got this
negative we've got this one third and
we've got this minus four so what do you
do first second third right well
the one third that comes in front we
could say that's going to be a vertical
shrink
by a factor of one third so basically
that's going to be squeezing it towards
the x-axis okay so it's making all the y
values one-third as high if you wanted
to kind of just visualize it in a rough
way here i could kind of show you it
would be a little bit wider and that's
because you're
squeezing it towards the x-axis making
all the y's one-third the height but
then what comes after that vertical
shrink let's see well we can see that we
have this negative here and that
negative is going to make all the
y values the opposite which is going to
then
take that graph and reflect it
over the x-axis so we're going to say
reflect
over the x-axis
and then the last step here is this
minus 4 and that minus 4 is going to
shift the graph
or translate the graph
down four units and so that would look
something like
uh the graph that we just did previously
and then it's going to be going down for
it now you can see this isn't on graph
paper so it's not perfect it's not exact
so don't hold me to that but the main
thing we're focusing on is what what
happens first second third now remember
how i said there's more than one way to
do these
well you could have also said
that the vertical
shrink came after the reflection over
the x-axis so you could have
interchanged those
however you wouldn't want to shift down
4 first and then reflect over the x-axis
that would that would not be the same
final graph so it's important that you
pay attention to the order of
transformations i oftentimes like to
think about working from
the inside out
and that's sometimes is a helpful way of
thinking about it and we're going to see
as we go into some more challenging
problems how to approach that
but in this case it was a vertical
shrink and then reflect over the x-axis
either one of those you could do first
and second and then the last one
shifting down four okay so for number
three now what did you get for the
parent function did you get y equals
square root of x so just keep in mind
when you graph the square root function
it looks something like that y equals
square root of x that's the basic graph
but now remember how we were talking
about okay order of transformations
we've got a couple things going on here
i like to start from the inside
and work my way out that's how i like to
think about it so
what i what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to say okay that minus x minus 1
that's grouped with the x okay so when
it's grouped with the x like that it's
going to shift the graph in the x
direction left and right right
but when it's grouped with the x like
that it has the opposite effect
okay minus 1 actually is going to shift
it to the right one
okay like that and if it was pulse one
it would shift it to the left one so for
this one the first uh
you know step here we could say is that
you're shifting
shift
right
one
okay now what about this five here in
front well the five is going to be a
vertical
stretch
okay by a factor of five okay so when i
say by a factor of five it means you're
multiplying all the y values by five and
what that does
in effect is basically like see how this
is zero well zero times five is still
zero so it's going to stay right where
it's at see this point right here where
it's like one well one times five is
five so it's going to now be way up here
so what's going to happen is the graph
is going to basically be pulled away
from the x-axis because you're
vertically stretching it by a factor of
5 or multiplying all those y-coordinates
by 5.
now in this particular problem
you can
do the vertical stretch by five first
and then shift right one
okay or the other way around so in this
case you could do it either way you're
still going to get the final uh same
graph but for me i often times like to
think just working from the inside out
just to kind of
just kind of stay consistent
but this one you're going to get the the
same graph either way whether you do the
shift right one and then vertical
stretch by factor of five or vice versa
okay so for number four
what did you get for the parent function
on this one did you get
y equals
x cubed so that's your your core
function you can kind of see that if you
were to eliminate some of these
extra numbers here you can see that's
your core
equation that you're dealing with but
then if we follow that process that i
mentioned earlier about basically
working from the inside out
we can see that we've got this 2 here
group with the x so what does that two
do when you it's a group with the x like
that well
we said that it has the opposite of
effect
and we know that it's
multiplied by the x which means that
it's going to actually
be a horizontal stretch or shrink but
because it's multiplied by the x like
that we know that it's going to be a
horizontal stretch or shrink but it's
going to be by the reciprocal by one
half so here i'm going to say horizontal
shrink
by a factor of one-half okay
now the next
step here
would be
the one-ninth so the one-ninth is going
to be a vertical
shrink
by a factor of one-ninth so that's going
to basically squeeze it towards the
x-axis because all the y-values are
one-ninth as much and the last step here
is this plus seven which is going to be
a
shift or a translation
up seven
now if we want to graph it just to do a
rough graph not an exact graph here
we'll take our parent function y equals
x cubed which looks something like this
the the 2x we said is actually going to
be a shrink so you're squeezing it
okay or multiplying all the x values by
one half so what that's going to do is
going to basically take this point here
and it's going to put it right here it's
going to take this point here it's going
to put it right here the point that's at
the origin when you multiply 0 times a
half it's still zero so what you're
going to get is you're going to get a
graph
like that that's been squeezed towards
the y-axis
now when you do the 1 9 in front here
this 1 9 you can see that's a vertical
shrink by a factor of 1 9. so it's going
to take this graph now the second one
here we did and it's going to squeeze it
towards the x axis okay basically all
these coordinates these y values are
going to be 1 9 as much and so what it's
going to do is basically squeeze it or
push it towards that x-axis
then the last step is going to then
shift it up seven okay now
like i said originally there's more than
one way to do some of these problems so
we could switch this horizontal shrink
and this vertical shrink we will still
get the same answer
but if you were to shift up seven first
and then try to do any of these other
steps you're going to get a different
final graph so you can do a horizontal
string vertical shrink and then shift up
seven or you could do the vertical
shrink horizontal shrink and then shift
up seven you've got a couple different
options on that one okay number five so
this one what did you get for the parent
function on on this one
well it looks like we have y equals
the cube root of x that's our core
function and just remember the cube root
function it it kind of looks something
like this again i'm not doing this on
graph paper so it's not exact but here
we're focusing on the transformations so
again like i like to do it i like to
basically identify that parent function
then i like to kind of start on the
inside to me this is on the inside
and work my way out
one thing you have to be careful though
on these little bit more complicated
problems is that
when you're working from the inside out
you actually want to think about
the reverse of the
pemdas or order of operations okay and
you can see here normally you would
think oh one half times x that's
multiplication right and then the plus
four that's addition you'd say normally
i do multiplication
first and then addition second when
you're simplifying right when we're
talking about the order of
transformations here we're going to
actually do the reverse we're going to
say the plus 4
is actually going to shift
the graph
left 4. and remember it looks like plus
4 but when it's group of the x like that
underneath that cube root it's going to
have the opposite effect it's actually
going to shift the graph
a left 4.
the one-half now the one-half x again
that's group of the x it's multiplied by
the x it's going to have the reciprocal
effect so it's actually going to be
a horizontal
stretch
by a factor of two not one half but two
it's the reciprocal
and then working our way out a little
bit further we've got this three and we
can see that the 3 is going to be a
vertical stretch
by a factor of 3
okay so it's going to multiply all the y
values by 3 and then this negative
is going to
reflect it
over
the x-axis so reflect over the x-axis
now
sometimes and let's just do the last
step and the last step then is this plus
2 which is going to shift the graph
up two units
now just another way to look at this
sometimes
students will ask they'll say well how
do you know whether it's having the
opposite effect or the same effect right
so let's talk a little bit about that
for just a quick second so what i like
to think of again is when it's grouped
with the x so it's kind of like you know
group either in parentheses and absolute
values underneath the square root or a
cube root you know it's grouped with the
x it has the opposite effect
opposite effect
and what's interesting when it's group
of the x like that it's affecting the
x values the horizontal direction okay
so if you can kind of remember that
group of the x affects the x coordinates
the x values the horizontal direction
and it has the opposite effect now if
it's not grouped like see how this
negative 3 is not group of the x
it's going to affect the y values and
it's going to have the same effects 3 is
actually going to multiply by 3 not 1 3
right so it's the same as as the number
three same thing with the plus two it's
going to actually shift it in the
positive direction up two
and when it's not grouped with the x
it's affecting the y coordinates it's
going in the y direction
so the little couple pointers there now
as far as could we have done this in a
different order so maybe you did this
and you said you know mario i didn't i
didn't get the same thing you did uh is
there another way that we could have
possibly done it
well
we could have we could have done the the
reflection over the x-axis
first and the vertical stretch by 3
first
that would be fine and then get into the
horizontal transformations
again you can switch these as well you
could say i'm going to do the
reflection second and the stretch first
or they could do the stretch
you know vice versa the one thing you
don't want to do is you don't want to
like shift it up to first and then start
doing the other transformations you're
going to get a different final graph
so a few different ways to do this you
could either work with these vertical
stretches and reflections and and then
do the horizontal here or you could do
the horizontal
and then do these once a second so more
than one option on this one as we get
into these more complicated problems
there's going to be a few more different
ways to do it
so at this point you might be asking
mario why is the quantity underneath the
radical
have like the opposite
effect from the order of operations when
you're determining the order of
transformations right well let's just
take a look a little bit here and just
kind of analyze like what's happening so
say if you had the cube root of x right
f of x equals a cube root of x that's
this blue graph right right here okay
that's this one right here and you can
see that if we wanted to do what we call
uh
like a composition of functions the way
functions work is that whatever's in the
parentheses it goes in for
the x on the right side of the equation
so wherever you see
x you're going to replace it with what's
inside of the parentheses now if we
wanted to create a new function let's
call it g of x
and we wanted to say well hm this is
going to be f of x plus 4 f of the
quantity x plus 4. but what's happening
now is you see where this x is right
here
this x is now going to be the quantity x
plus 4 and that's going to go in for x
on the right side of the equation it's
going to be replaced with that so you
can see
g of x is now going to be equal to the
cube root
of x plus 4.
now knowing what we talked about earlier
x plus 4 is going to do what it's going
to shift the graph not positive 4 but
it's going to shift it actually to the
left 4. so you can see this point here 1
1
okay now is going to be over here at
negative 3 1.
and sometimes students say well i don't
get it like plus 4 why doesn't it shift
it right 4 well
you can see like if you were to put 1
in for x right here the square root of 1
is going to give you this y value of 1
right
now with this new function right here
the cube root of x plus 4 if you put
negative 3 in for x
negative 3 plus 4 is 1 the cube root of
1 is 1. so you can see you're getting
that same output that same y value but
what happened to your x value it had to
be
for less for smaller right so that's
what's shifting the graph in the x axis
direction 4 units to the left
that makes sense
now if you wanted to take it one step
further okay let's say h of x now
we're going to do h of x equals g of 1
half x so what do we do we say well
whatever's in the parentheses the one
half x
is going to go in place of x on the
right it's a substitution so we're
replacing x with one half x and that's
giving us our equation here now h of x
equals the cube root of one half x plus
four
but look at it here what actually did we
do first and then second
well you can see we actually shifted the
graph left four
right
and then we did a horizontal stretch
by a factor of 2. so when you're looking
underneath this parentheses here you
might say one half x plus 4 i
do a horizontal stretch by 2 and then i
shift left 4. but that's not actually
what happened when we did this
composition of functions where we were
kind of building up this function from
the apparent function what we did first
was we
replaced x with x plus 4 which shifted
the graph of f4
and then we replaced x with one half x
right here
and that
that became the one half x plus four so
really when you're describing the order
of transformations that's why this plus
four
uh
was the shifting left and right before
we did the
horizontal stretch by a factor of two it
sounds a little bit backwards because
you think hmm why is addition coming
before multiplication
you know that's kind of the opposite of
the order of operations but here we're
talking about the order of
transformations meaning how the graph is
transformed okay so for number six what
did you get for the parent function did
you get y equals
the greatest integer
function
so y equals this these double bars here
if you remember it's the greatest
integer function and sometimes called
the step function it looks like stairs
and you can see it's closed on the left
open on the right remember whatever
when you're evaluating whatever is
inside of here
you're always going to round down or to
the left on the number line to the
nearest integer so that's referred to as
the greatest integer function but even
if you don't know that you can still
talk through the
order of transformations which we're
going to do right now and so let's see
so in this one if i was using that
technique that i like which is to work
from the inside out
i would start by working inside of this
these double brackets here
okay this greatest integer function and
i would say to myself hmm
i know when i'm grouped with x like that
on the inside it's the opposite of the
order of operations so what i mean by
that is
normally i would see this 2 is
multiplied and then i'd see this x minus
4 okay that's subtracted and i also see
i've got some parentheses there so when
i think of the pemdas what comes first
we've got parentheses
and then multiplication right
but
we said we're going to do the opposite
when it's group of the x like that so
we're actually going to do this too this
multiplication first we're going to say
that it's going to be a horizontal
shrink
by a factor of one-half meaning we're
going to multiply all the x values by
one-half
that's going to squeeze it
towards the y axis because all the x
coordinates are half as much right
then we're going to get into the
x minus 4 which is going to be shifting
okay shifting the graph
right
four units so it's gonna pick it up
basically and move it over four units
remember stretching and shrinking you're
you're basically like pulling on it
you're you're multiplying right but when
you're shifting you're picking it up and
lifting it kind of like a
rigid transformation they refer to it as
and then setting it down in this case
right four
okay then continuing our journey working
our way from the inside out this one
half is going to be a vertical shrink
by a factor of one-half
and then lastly
working our way from the inside out the
minus one is going to be a translation
or a shift
down
one remember the minus one down one so
again minus one this is not group of the
x it has the same effect negative is
down one if it was plus one it would go
up one if it's group of the x like this
four
it looks like minus four normally you'd
think oh minus four is to the left or
negative four but it's grouped with that
x it has the opposite effect that shifts
right 4.
so this again is just one way of doing
this
order of
transformations another way to do it if
you didn't want to do it in the way i've
listed here is we could have done the
vertical shrink first make that number
one right and then we could have worked
with the translations on the inside here
of the
double brackets right we could have done
the
horizontal shrink second and then the
shift right three and then finally that
shift down would be four again you don't
want to switch the number two and three
okay that order is important as we
listed it but you could do the vertical
shrink uh
ahead of those okay or like i list them
originally here so a couple different
options
let's go on to the next one okay for
number seven what did you get for the
parent function
did you get y equals one over x that's
referred to as the reciprocal function
it's actually like a hyperbola that
looks something like this where you've
got kind of two
curves facing
uh
opposite one another like that in the
first and third quadrants that's your
basic graph there
but now talking about the
order of transformations what do we do
first second third
well again i like to kind of start
from the inside and work my way out so
i'm looking at that x here i see this x
plus 8 and i know that when it's group
of the x like that okay it has the
opposite effect so i'm going to say that
this
shifts
left
eight so the plus eight looks like it's
gonna normally you'd think oh plus eight
to the right eight or positive eight but
it has the opposite effect when it's
grouped with that x it's going to go
left 8.
and then if we go
again working our way from the
inside out we're going to look at this 3
here and what does that 3 do that 3 is
actually like 3
times 1 over x right so it's it's going
to actually
multiply all the y values by 3 it's
going to be a vertical stretch
by a factor of 3
and then we can see there's a minus sign
here and that minus sign is multiplied
by that whole quantity there and so what
that minus sign does it's not grouped
with the x it's not on the inside it's
on the outside it's going to actually
make all the y values the opposite which
is going to reflect this graph
over the x-axis keep in mind if the
y-values here become the opposite it's
going to be on the other side of the
x-axis right
okay and so then now last thing is this
2 here and this 2 i could have just as
easily put over here and made it plus
two
that would have been a little bit i
think more
intuitive and you can certainly do that
when you see a problem if it doesn't
look like you know it's
in a way that you're used to seeing it
you can move it to the other side like
that it's just a positive two or plus
two so that's going to shift the graph
or translate the graph up two units
right
okay now looking at this order of
transformations is there a way that we
could have done this differently than
the way that i've listed it here
well we could have done the vertical
stretch
first okay by a factor of three
and then we could have even reflected it
over the x-axis and then we could have
shifted it left eight okay and then
shifted up two that would be another way
of doing it another way to do it would
be to reflect it first you could reflect
it over the x-axis and then do the
stretch vertically by a factor of 3 then
shift it left 8 and then shift it
up to last so you've got a few different
options here
of how you want to order these
transformations however you do not want
to do that plus two first and then
proceed to do the other ones you're
going to get a different final graph
okay this last problem is kind of a
chicken
i say chicken it's a kitchen sink uh
type of a problem because it has
everything in this problem i mean almost
almost everything i guess we could have
thrown a few more things in here but
it's got a lot so it's kind of a
challenging one so the first thing is to
start off with is basically identifying
the parent function so the parent
function
you can see it's an absolute value
function that's our basic graph now
talking about the order of
transformations again if you want to
follow the way that i kind of like to
think about it working from the inside
out okay
so when you look at it here you say to
yourself hmm
okay when i start on the inside i know i
want to do the opposite of that pemdas
or that order of operations i've got
multiplication or by that 3
i've got the parentheses x plus 1 is in
parentheses and i also have this
negative here as well
so
let's think about this here so normally
we would do parentheses first right
but we have this multiplication and we
said that okay with the pemdas we're
going to do with the reverse so i'm
going to do the multiplication first so
i'm going to look at that 3 and i'm
going to say that this is a
horizontal
shrink
by a factor of not three but one third
remember when it's group of the x like
that it has the
reciprocal effect
now the negative here
okay it's group of that x what that
negative is gonna do is it's to make all
the x values the opposite so it's going
to be a reflection
over
the y axis not the x axis because it's
making the x values the opposite right
and then lastly now we've got that plus
one in parentheses which is going to
shift the graph horizontally because
it's affecting the x
coordinates the x values and it's going
to shift it not plus 1
but to the left one it's the opposite
right when it's grouped with the x like
that it's grouped inside it's going to
have the opposite effect shifting left
one now working our way further out
we've got this one half
which again remember when it's not group
of the x it's affecting the y values
okay up and down
the y coordinates and so this is going
to have the same effect it's going to be
a
vertical
shrink
by a factor of one half
and then this negative here in front is
going to make all the y values the
opposite sign which reflects
the graph over
the x-axis right if you make all the y
values the opposite they're going to be
the mirror image over the x-axis and
then lastly
we've got that minus 8 which is going to
shift the graph in the y direction the
same as the sign here the negative which
is going to shift it down
8. now this problem had
a lot of different transformations in it
and we could have done this
in some a different order than what i
have listed here there's uh many
different combinations so i'll leave it
to maybe some uh input from you in the
comments and other commenters as well to
discuss which methods that you decided
to use for this one but just make sure
you don't do that minus 8
shifting down 8 first that would
definitely give you a different final
graph
nice thing is you can check these by
graphing them on a graphing calculator
and you can kind of
walk through it and see if you're
getting the same result so
great job
i i'll show you another video that i did
talking more about the graphs so you can
kind of get more experience with how to
graph using transformations and not just
describe them
and i'll put that on the screen here and
if you want to
learn more about these types of problems
go ahead and check out my channel i've
got some playlists there
and i look forward to seeing in the next
video